please be seated president Bollinger on
behalf of the Dean the faculty and the
Columbia College class of 2017 I
respectfully ask your permission to
begin these class-a exercises thank you
[Applause]
president Bollinger vice president
Madigan Dean Valentini MS Wright
[Applause]
distinguished faculty esteemed alumni
and guests I am proud to recognize the
members of the class of 2017 and marked
their shared and individual
accomplishments in these class day
exercises at this time I would like to
invite Jordan and Erin president a
president of the Columbia College class
of 2017 to the podium Thank You Matthew
okay hi everyone
it's a warm Oh it's a warm day in the
beginning of April but I'm cooped up
deep inside the labyrinth that is our
Student Center fidgeting on a backless
stool that accommodates the near but not
quite entire circumference of my behind
crossing my legs the way I've seen in
movies I feel my underarms begin to
sweat cosmic payback I assume for
waiting to take my senior portraits
until the last possible date a
photographer shifts my neck and angular
chin to the left like I'm a Barbie doll
with extremities that swivel and then
tells me to stay put he reaches for an
anger and grabbed the graduation cap and
gown like an expert he cocoons me in a
light blue polyester draping it over my
body
crowning it atop my head then he grabs
the mirror holds it up to my face and
asked what I think what I think is
[Applause]
what I think is this is actually
happening what I think is I'm not ready
staring back at me in the mirror is a
girl who looks like she knows what she's
doing with her life or at least what she
wants to do with the next five to ten
years of it what a fraud the
photographer puts down the mirror and
positions himself behind the camera aims
its lens at my costume self he asks if
I'm all set and then clicks before I can
respond before I can say no wait I'm not
I went lately there's a sentiment I
sensed tiptoeing around our collective
consciousness the one that popped into
my head while I was being photographed
but says we're supposed to have it all
figured out by now that says we should
be walking out of the iron gates on
Broadway and 116th Street this afternoon
was a job and a part
men with prospects for a spouse and dog
and 2.5 kids that says we've failed if
we still don't know it wasn't always
like this we enter college as teenagers
relatively unaware of and unexposed to
life outside our northern New Jersey
suburb or capital cities across the
globe but we're comfortable in our
confusion we got into Colombia after all
so we step onto campus and float along
for a bit our body is filled with hot
air unafraid of the unknown we join all
the clubs meet all the friends try all
the things we venture outside of
Morningside Heights and make the city
our playground we decide to take
Sanskrit we declare ourselves to be
undecided literally when asked about our
majors and figuratively when asked about
anything else the world is our oyster
and even those of us who keep kosher or
pit up but then something happens to
deflate us we get a C on our first lit
home essay we apply to a summer
internship and get rejected or worse get
no response at all we gain the freshman
15 or the sophomore 17 we spend an
entire weekend in bed waiting for a text
that never comes
or not that erosion gradual leaves and
then all at once we learned the hard way
how the foreign can be frightful the
unpredictable unnerving and as a result
we start to view our I don't knows as
naive and strive for certainties instead
it makes sense
answers are neater than questions but in
a pressurized race to figure it all out
we've forgotten there's no deadline for
uncertainty we forgotten that it's okay
to not know forgotten that none of us
really do in an effort to avoid the road
less traveled we forgotten that the
truth is most of us have barely stepped
foot on the past I still don't know what
I want to do where I want to go who I
want to be and if I figure it out and
then change my mind when I'm 23 and when
I'm 89 and every day in between I have
to think that makes me lucky if you wake
up tomorrow or in a year or a decade
from now and decide you no longer know
something you once thought you did I
think that makes you lucky too we're all
lucky we got to spend four years at this
magical and often infuriating place
asking questions and trying new things
and continuously changing our minds we
knew uncertainty was okay and when we
pack up our bag today or tomorrow or
this weekend
and finally inevitably eventually leave
this place this bubble that's about to
burst I hope we remember it's tellers
the future is ours 2017 congratulations
not just for today but for every day of
the past four years and every day to
come I love you all
before I continue I promised my little
brother I would take a selfie so I'm
going to do that okay thanks also happy
early birthday Brennan now I'm thrilled
to introduce our keynote speaker
president and CEO of United Way of New
York City scheana right miss Wright
entered miss Wright entered Columbia at
the age of 16 as an undergraduate in
Columbia College she co-founded the
pan-african house
hedid the cultural affairs committee of
the black students organization was
president of the road chapter of Delta
Sigma Theta and lettered in varsity
track and field and cross country he
then attended Columbia Law School where
she where she graduated as a Harlan
Fiske stone scholar for how standing
academic achievement she went on to
become the second female
african-american lawyer in the history
of Wachtel Lipton Rosen and pass as as
former president and CEO of Abyssinian
Development Corporation she led
revitalization efforts in education
housing economic development and human
services including the building of the
first new public high school in Harlem
in over 50 years the Thurgood Marshall
called the third red Marshall Academy
for learning and social change when she
took the reins in her current role as
president and CEO of the United Way of
New York City on the very day that
hurricane sandy hit she became the first
ever female CEO in organizations nearly
80 year history
but she met that challenge and many
others actual izing a collective impact
strategy refocusing the organization to
ensure that it is connecting people at
the benefits driving to double the
number of children reading proficiently
by 2020 and working to help our
struggling neighbors become
self-sufficient ladies and gentlemen
please join me in welcoming a fierce
advocate for children our neighbors our
community and each and every one of us
machinery
Wow defining tilapia
oh thank you thank you thank you so much
for all of that love Thank You Jordanna
you are a for Columbia College women in
the house I know we are celebrating 30
years of women at Columbia College I am
so proud and pleased that the leader of
the class of 2017 is those fabulous
fierce Jordanna
I want to thank president Bollinger and
Dean tini
thank you so much for having me I want
to thank the trustees the faculty and
administration really for giving me this
true honor I got the chance to process
in with the faculty and the spirit of
camaraderie and all of the love that is
in this place is truly amazing this is a
special place I want to thank my family
and friends who have joined me today and
all of my comrades from the late 80s
Early 90s ank you as well and thank you
class of 2017 for having me thank you
thank you I would say it is always great
walking through those gates remembering
my college days as you heard I entered
Columbia when I was 16 and that was 31
years ago you could do the math yes I
was a young girl from the South Bronx
who came yes right the Bronx was in the
house
I came to Columbia by way of a boarding
school in Pennsylvania the world was
very very different then Nelson Mandela
was still in prison and apartheid was
still the law of the land in South
Africa graffiti was seen as a public
nuisance and not high art as it is today
hip-hop was described as a sad that
would human pass away Ronald Reagan was
the President of the United States
passing the torch to George HW Bush in
my senior year and when I graduated the
30 year fixed mortgage rate was over 9%
yes up there's more to add insult to
injury there was no internet can you
believe that no cell phones no personal
computers and there were actually books
in Butler I mean you actually had to go
there and search for them and pull them
off the shelves and read them in order
to get your work done I mean it was it
was just I know right can you believe
that I distinctly remember I had to
write my senior thesis all 50 pages of
it in longhand and my dear for I know
you guys probably don't even know how to
write in lingerie all right my dear
friend and sorority sister who was a
master typist she typed it up for me and
thankfully she edited it heavily along
the way and I had she did it on a word
processor you don't know what that is I
then had to sprint across campus to hand
it in to none other to Professor Eric
Foner this was here today one of my
heroes there was no email people and
thank you Eric Foner thank you professor
Foner for your stewardship your guidance
all that you poured into me and so many
of us we are so grateful well so much
about the world and Columbia has changed
from the time I walked along college
walk as a student so much is actually
really the same when I came to Columbia
like most of you I quickly found my
community the athletes right the track
team
the revolutionaries on the black steel
organization those submitted to public
service of Delta Sigma Theta Sorority
the journey
I traveled 31 years ago was actually
very much like yours I became firmly
grounded in the core
even as I railed against it like I know
you did right and like some of you I
know I turn in my last assignment by the
skin of my teeth
and I finally finally passed the dreaded
swim test I mean I struggled like you as
I travel through Colombia I made my mark
on this place and it made its mark on me
and like you I sat in my seat during
class day in the midst of all of the
wonderful celebration and the midst of
the cheering and the giving of things I
remember sitting here with a healthy
dose of anxiety anxiety about what's
next what is on the other side of this
day my task for the next few minutes is
to give you a little sneak peek about
what is on the other side of this day
and to also share with you what I would
suggest you need for the journey ahead
and last but not least class of 2017 I
want to share with you what we need so
desperately from you first what should
you expect what is on the other side of
this day you heard me describe the era I
came of age and at Columbia and the
first thing you should expect is that
the world will change dramatically and
unexpectedly I think you all probably
know this more than most the global
changes politically economically and
socially and just the span of time that
you have been at Columbia have already
been dramatic just
unbelievable changes the question will
be as Columbo gret Columbia graduates
will you be drivers of that change or
will you simply be impacted by it the
second thing you should expect is that
on the other side of this day you will
have enormous personal responsibility
and not just paying your student loans
because that is enormous and they will
find you not just supporting yourself
financially and figuring out how to pay
rent and still go out to dinner every
once in a while but also the
responsibility that comes from taking
care of others your family members
children one day your parents and
caregivers even but also the
responsibility of taking care of
institutions the ones that you work for
the ones that you will create and the
ones that you will support institutions
like Columbia like the United Way as
Columbia graduates the question will be
how do you execute that responsibility
will it be with commitment and passion
or will it be half-hearted grudging
fearful the third thing I want to share
with you that is that you will have
unexpected personal challenges an
unexpected personal triumph some of you
I know are planners I had a classmate I
mean she planned her entire life path
Columbia she was going to get married at
25 start having children at 27 get her
doctorate by 29 and be a tenured
professor at 31 I on the other hand
wasn't going to even think about getting
married and having children until I was
maybe 35 and I was going into the Peace
Corps directly out of Columbia and I was
probably going to live in South Africa
and be a freedom fighter that is what I
knew sure needless to say she never got
married
and had children and I got married and
had my first child immediately after
college shocking and I started my career
at Wachtel lips and Rosen & Katz the
most preeminent corporate law firm in
the world of five far cry from South
Africa that just goes to show that
whether you've got it all planned out or
whether you're someone who is a bit more
laid back and floats along
regardless you will have challenges and
triumphs that will rock your world you
will deal with death disease the loss of
a job you'll be faced with an ethical
dilemma at work or at home and you will
have amazing triumph winning battles
that seemed unwinnable reaching Heights
that you could not have imagined and
finding personal fulfilment happiness
and satisfaction that is so deep and
abiding that sometimes you just have to
pinch yourself wondering what you did to
deserve at all and the question will be
as Columbia graduates do you feel a
priest fully appreciate benefit and
learn from these triumphs and challenges
or will you just get through them losing
what their full impact is meant to be on
your life I know none of this is rocket
science and perhaps seems so obvious to
your twenty something cells sure they'll
be significant change in the world sure
you'll have significant personal
responsibilities and of course you will
have personal challenges and personal
triumphs you've probably experienced all
of these things already but on the other
side of this day the stakes are much
higher higher than they've ever been and
what I want to leave you with is a few
suggestions of what you will need on the
other side of this day some suggestions
to help you drive change execute your
personal responsibilities with
commitment and passion and to firmly
appreciate benefit and learn from the
challenges and triumphs that you will
face
just see three things that you will need
on the other side of this day the first
is openness the second is curiosity and
finally and most importantly in acute
appreciation of your power and influence
openness really truly being open to
hearing and trying to understand a
different point of view have mercy we
need that so much in the days today when
I told you about my days at Columbia I
described fighting my community my
community of athletes revolutionaries
those committed to public service but
what they really were were my tribes one
of the things you learn here is how to
become firmly entrenched in a specific
ideology at Columbia we have been known
to draw battle lines around our beliefs
and to fight to the death around them
and I understand while while you're here
you're coming of age you're trying to
figure out who you are in the world and
it's important to put a stake in the
ground but on the other side of this day
I challenge you the class of 2017 to be
open get outside of your tribe and
really try and hear and connect with
others that have a different point of
view
you'll be so surprised by what you can
and will accomplish when you do I run
the United Way of New York City it's a
nearly 80 year old nonprofit that has
strong ties to the corporate sector we
are committed to helping low-income New
Yorkers achieve a level of
self-sufficiency and I have to tell you
that almost half my board all successful
and accomplished people our Columbia
College graduate there's no surprise
there across many generations and many
of them I will tell you I would have
never even talked to during my days on
campus I would have declared them my
ideological enemies because they belong
to groups to tribe that had a different
worldview than my own others on my board
would have been comrades in arms we
would have been getting arrested
together as we chained ourselves to
Hamilton Hall like we like to do but as
different as our experiences and points
of views were and even are now by being
open and really willing to listen and
hear someone with a different point of
view
what you will find is that there is care
commitment and concern for the very same
thing we all want a healthy vibrant city
and nation where there's opportunity for
all whether we call ourselves Democrats
Republicans or independents we all have
common goals and desires and at the
United Way of New York City the
institution so many Columbia graduates
are responsible for stewarding we are
open and committed to one another to
achieve those common goals and desires
and we are having a significant impact
and moving the needle for low-income New
Yorkers in this city the second thing
you will need on this journey is healthy
curiosity always try to find a lesson in
everything when you're experiencing
challenges and even the triumphs always
ask yourself what is the lesson in this
how did I get here what can I learn from
this experience to make me better and
help others if Columbia does anything it
Stokes your passion for learning
don't lose it as you move forward and
finally and this is the most important
suggestion I have for you on this
journey ahead know your power Columbia
class of 2017 you have enormous power
and influence and you need to use it
well your education your tenacity that
brought you to this moment your
experiences they all endow you with
significant power even if you don't
quite realize it today even if you are
unsure on the other side of this day you
will walk into situations where you're
going to be the most junior person in
the room but your lack of experience
does not denote a lack of power
I'm always encouraged
by a story told by one of the former
mayors of the city of New York Mayor
David Dinkins who also is a Columbia
professor he told the story about how he
was at this very very fancy banquet and
he was the mayor and he had a tuxedo on
and he was seated at the table and the
server came around that had and he had a
plate of butter and Mayor Dinkins said
I'd like another pat of butter and the
server said no everyone just gets one
pad of butter
the mayor said no no I want another pad
of butter I want some more butter on my
bread and the service said no no
everyone just one pad of butter and the
mayor said Do You Know Who I am I am the
mayor of the city of New York and the
service said Do You Know Who I am
and the mayor said well who are you he
said I'm the guy with the butter the
moral of the story is to realize your
power you've got the butter but also to
appreciate the power of others yes
and finally Columbia class of 2017 in
the midst of the world changing as
significantly and dramatically as it is
in the midst of executing your
tremendous personal responsibilities in
the midst of experiencing your own
personal challenges and triumphs you
have an obligation a duty a birthright
as graduates of Columbia to be open to
be curious and to use your power to
drive change in the world with
commitment and passion now why do I say
as Columbia graduates are these edicts
more relevant to you than any other
graduates I say absolutely yes
Columbia is a very special place I
cannot think of another institution with
the academic rigor the grounding in the
core that gives you such an expansive
foundation an institution with all of
this that sits smack in the middle of
one of the most populous vibrant and
diverse cities on the planet yes class
of 2017 you have a unique responsibility
as Columbia graduates to drive change in
the world with commitment and passion
the responsibility and example has been
passed down from our forefathers like
Alexander Hamilton if you haven't seen
the play I know you know the soundtrack
right from my classmates 31 years ago
and all of the classes that marched in
the procession before you Columbia is
the place that forges leaders that
assume awesome responsibilities and on
the other side of this day we have an
extremely divided world and we need
Columbia graduates to be open and lead
the way the challenges that are facing
our city 2.7 million New Yorkers cannot
make ends meet while 83% of those
households has somebody that goes to
work every single day we have 70 percent
of children in New York City public
schools that cannot read on grade level
climate change we have a skills gap
where employers cannot find the
qualified people they need to fill the
jobs that they have global terror racism
discrimination income inequality we need
you Columbia graduates like as Alexander
Hamilton and many of those that came
before cannot only think of your
personal success but to take on the
responsibility of solving the problems
that are waiting for us on the other
side of this day
because you can be a class of 2017 based
on your unique experiences you actually
have what it takes and it is your
birthright and your responsibility to do
what I know what we all know you're
capable of doing and I will end with
this lin-manuel Miranda really captured
Alexander Hamilton and the word that he
ascribed to our forefather who actually
lived in Harlem by the way in the brief
song in the play history has its eyes on
you Alexander Hamilton says in this
moment let me tell you what I wish I'd
known when I was young and dreamed of
glory you have no control of who lives
who dies who tells your story I know we
can win I know what greatness lies
within you but remember from here on in
history has its eyes on you on the other
side of this day Columbia class of 2017
history has its eyes on you make us
proud
thank you
thank you Miss right there is a lot of
love here for you today thank you and
thank you to the class of 2017
for your passion and dedication to our
community now we turn our attention to a
few graduates who like Miss Wright have
inspired and uplifted our Columbia
community during their time here in each
class there are students who
distinguished themselves in their school
through superior academic
accomplishments and service to others
over the past few weeks we have
recognized students who have been
particularly gracious with their time
and talents their efforts have enhanced
our community in so many ways at this
time I asked those students who received
academic or athletic awards and prizes
were selected as senior marshals were
honored with a graduation cord at a
variety of ceremonies or who were
recognized as a leadership an excellence
award ceremony or other celebration -
please stand
[Music]
we applaud your commitment and abilities
and are grateful for your contributions
to Columbia I am fortunate to have known
and worked alongside so many of you it
is a great honor for me now to present
our first class day award the Charles M
roll core prize to Elsa mitosis Hoover
whose classmates have deemed her worthy
a special distinction for scholarships
participation and student activities
preeminence in athletics or any
combination of these two give just a
sampling of Elsa's campus involvement
she is being recognized for her
leadership within the Native American
and indigenous communities at Columbia
[Applause]
Elsa has served a coordinator of the
Manhattan house for the past two years
and as a respected senior in the Native
American Council this year also played a
key leadership role in activism against
the Dakota access pipeline as the
principal organizer of Columbia's
Standing Rock pieces
the only undergraduate student serving
on the New York City stands for standing
rock collective and a key contributor to
the nationally noted stand Rock syllabus
please join us in congratulating Elsa I
[Applause]
would now like to invite Lisa Halawa
scene of academic planning and
administration to present the recipients
of this year's academic award good
morning on behalf of the faculty is now
my honor to present for awards for
academic achievement the Albert Asher
green Memorial Prize the David B Truman
Alumni Award and the honors of
salutatorian and valedictorian the
Albert Asher Greene Memorial Prize was
established by mr. and mrs. Asher Greene
in memory of their son Alberta green
class of 1914 this prize is awarded to
the senior who has been a student and
good standing in the college for at
least three years and who was made the
best record of scholarship the 2017
prize is awarded to die Allen
Roger etem
sigh Alan is graduating this year with
both a major in financial economics and
a concentration in mathematics and he
has not only established a record that
his faculty described as extraordinary
in these subjects but he's also
performed at the highest level in all of
the coursework that he's taken toward
the core curriculum as a result Diane
earned the distinction of graduating the
highest grade point average for the
class of 2017 congratulations
the david be terminal um nyah award was
established to honor David V Truman
former dean of the college and is given
to the Columbia College student who has
made the most distinguished contribution
to the academic affairs of the college
this year's recipients is George Liu in
2015 George was graduating with a major
in economics it was one of the winners
of the course scholars competition after
creating a 3d printed miniature torso
that was inspired by Plato's Republic he
then served from 2015 to 2017 on the
core scholars committee organizing the
yearly competition and serving as one of
its judges furthermore from 2015 to 2017
George served as a student
representative on the Committee on the
Corps where he not only contributed to
discussions held among the very faculty
chairs of the various core classes but
he also helped to select the winners of
the core preceptor teaching awards
congratulations George
[Applause]
from among those students with the
highest GPAs in the class the
salutatorian and valedictorian are
selected by the Faculty Committee on
honours awards and prizes to make their
selections the committee relies on
faculty recommendations for these
students that speak to the strengths
breadth depth and rigour of their
academic achievements as well as the
evidence of their intellectual promise
their character and their achievements
outside the classroom I am now pleased
to recognize the salutatorian for the
class of 2017 long-play you
a you who is graduating with a major in
art history and a concentration in
anthropology also studied abroad in
spring 2016 at Columbia's Reed Hall
program in Paris she speaks French and
Mandarin as in currently learning German
allo Ken Kim foundation scholar for art
history from 2014 through 2017
she has interned at the American
Federation of Arts through the Columbia
arts experience the Asia art archive in
America and Singapore's National Gallery
and she's currently developing workshops
which she will facilitate at Singapore's
open festival in summer 2017 which is a
public engagement initiative of the
Singapore International Festival of Arts
who also serves as a board member for
the Columbia University artists society
and she is a volunteer with Rita head a
nonprofit organization that matches
elementary school students with reading
mentors for weekly reading sessions
congratulations
I am now pleased to recognize the
valedictorian for the class of 2017
Michael Abulafia
Michael who's graduating with a major in
English was inducted into junior Phi
Beta Kappa in January of this year in
summer 2016 you received the Richmond V
Williams traveling fellowship to conduct
independent research at the BBC's
written archive Center in Reading
England where he uncovered writings by
major 20th century authors which were
unknown to current scholars and he hopes
to publish these findings later this
year
Michael is co-editor of the book of Jays
a book likes length scholarly addition
of a collection of Victorian poetry and
also of dead reckonings a scholarly
periodical in the field of Gothic
literature his writing has been featured
in the New York Daily News Brooklyn
magazine and literary journals such as
teacher Lovecraft annual spectrum realms
sunlit and the Edison literary review
next year he will return to England to
pursue Graduate Studies in the master's
program in English at the University of
Oxford please help me congratulate
Michael and welcome him to the podium
[Applause]
[Music]
it was worried that I would get up here
and forget how to read but
thank you for that very generous
introduction Jean Halawa in my younger
and more vulnerable years can they long
ago of my first semesters at Columbia
when I was still using lines from famous
American novels by F scott Fitzgerald as
introductions I felt a tremendous sense
of anxiety about the idea of tradition a
university as storied and decorated as
Columbia is bound to feel solemn
hallowed when arriving in Morningside
Heights for the first time during n stop
I remember studiously reading a list of
dozens of activities tradition songs
myths and legends that for some are
emblems of what it means to be a
Columbia student there's Oregon Knight
and alma mater Dowell there's the tree
lighting ceremony in long afternoons at
the Hungarian pastry shop there's primal
scream and a familiar roster of must
take classes with stary professors some
of these traditions are sort of
institutional others bloom organically
across generations of students but as
much as we can find joy and fascination
and mystery in this history I wonder too
if the Platonic ideal of a Columbia
student a person defined by his or her
participation in a certain set of
activities or commitments isn't somehow
misleading for long and rewarding years
have passed since end table and I doubt
if I partake in in more than a handful
of these traditions my regrets are few
although this like most things is
seasonal I can't talk about what a
Columbia experience is or isn't but I
can talk about what it is or isn't for
me I wonder if there is such a thing as
a typical or average Columbia experience
at all the lived realities of myself and
my peers seem to indicate otherwise it's
easy and simple and reassuring suggests
that we're all bound to one another
through a shared set of traditions but
as I've come to understand reading
literature and through life its
misguided to seek takeaways or life
lessons that are this rigidly formulaic
and one-size-fits-all
figuring out the real questions one has
as opposed to searching for answers is a
far more important and far more
difficult undertaking Colombia is not
only its traditions or its legacy but an
ongoing unfolding set of potential
opportunities for me Colombia was in a
four-year series of useful occasions an
occasion to question and even distrust
my own motives and compulsions an
occasion to intimately understand
humility by exposing myself to
brilliance an occasion to perform secret
kindnesses for friends and strangers
because many of the most important
things that we've done aren't listed on
our resumes an occasion to cultivate my
inner life for the best of my ability an
occasion to succeed in to falter an
occasion to consider and frequently
abandon the traditions that feel neat
identifying comforting uniting life and
its problems don't have ready-made
answers there are no easily digestible
road maps to becoming the good citizens
saints and sages that we all dream of
becoming traditions are made every day
the moment they restrict you you're
being called to forge your own but
Colombia has changed my life and I think
has changed all of us by offering a
guided space to know myself to look
inward before looking outward to wonder
the friendships I've made the
professor's I've studied with those
elements that have come to define my
time at Colombia in short have taught me
a great deal about what the writer of
bell hooks wisely called the complex
accounting of life to put things in
perspective weigh things to see what
different moral universes and worldviews
have to offer in thought and in action
the rest is up to us here's our own
expectations our own traditions our own
varied experiences which come not from a
history that's been left to us but from
the 1172 histories that we all as
individuals are in the process of
creating congratulations the remarkable
class of 2017
I would now like to call forward Doug
Wolfe graduate of the Columbia College
class of 1988 and current president of
the Columbia College Alumni Association
Doug who graduated with a Bachelor of
Arts and physics was on the wrestling
team dorm council board of managers and
performed as a piano accompanying us to
a variety of student musicians today he
is a leading intellectual property
attorney at the firm of Wolfe Greenfield
in Boston where he works with clients
from startups to multinational
corporations on a wide variety of
matters including counseling on patents
trademarks licensing and litigations
Doug has been recognized by his peers
and international organizations with
awards for both his professional work
and his support to the business
community he has also written many
articles and has appeared on television
in radio please join me in welcoming
Doug Wolfe to the podium on behalf of
the almost 50,000 alumni of Columbia
College I welcome students parents
family and friends
congratulations Columbia College class
of 2017 I understand that this could be
the best class ever
today we honor your hard work and
commitment that has allowed you to
accomplish this goal as alumni we are
proud and impressed by the height that
you have reached at Columbia and we were
thrilled to have you join us in the next
and lifelong phase as a Colombian you
may have graduated from Columbia College
but your connection to the school and
its community has not ended as you join
the ranks of many former students before
you you will find that so much of your
future your choices and your experiences
will have you reflecting on your time
here at Columbia College you have
lessons both inside and outside the
classroom that will continue to bear
fruit in your future endeavors in ways
that you cannot foresee your experiences
experiences here as individuals and as a
class will shape you more than you can
imagine today from the core curriculum
to jumbo slices a coronet from college
walk to that city out there these
experiences have connected generations
of Colombians before and will continue
to after you now you're a lifelong
member of our Columbia College Alumni
Association a embodying perhaps lead it
into the future enjoy this moment
remember your classmates keep in touch
this is an important network both
socially and professionally that can
support you for the rest of your life
the Columbia College Alumni Association
will be the hub that unites you with
your classmates or other alumni with
similar interests or the faculty who
will still have much to share we look
forward to having you join our thousands
of engaged alumni we look forward to
working with newly minted alumni to form
our leadership ranks now and long into
the future to teach us where to go as an
organization but we need you to be
involved in the same way that you have
shaped the college during your four
years on campus we know that you can
help us to continue to build our dynamic
alumni community with your energy your
passion and your relentless pursuit of
excellence interview prospective
students
sir current students gather your
classmates together for social events
and professional networking stay
connected to the faculty energized the
Columbia departments with your new found
knowledge once again congratulations to
the Columbia College class of 2017 it is
now my honor to present three awards on
behalf of the Columbia College Alumni
Association the Alumni prize is awarded
to Brennan Kean Mendez Brennan has been
judged by classmates to be the most
faithful and deserving Brennan served as
vice president on the Columbia College
student council for the class of 2017 he
helped found and Cheer the mental health
task force pushing for more diversity on
the Counseling and Psychological
Services staff so that students of all
identities would be represented when
seeking counsel Brennan was also a
member of the Advisory Committee on
socially responsible investing leading
Columbia to be the first University in
the nation to divest from prison private
prisons
I understand this is the abridged
version too so president Brennan is a
true champion of social justice leading
the way to what is right rather than
following crowds
congratulations Brennan the Robert
Lincoln Carey Memorial Prize is awarded
to jeremy cooper jeremy who through a
combination of leadership qualities best
exemplifies the ideals which Robert
Lincoln Carey sought to engender in the
students of Columbia College
Jeremy created events including basement
vbq in Halloween extreme extravaganza to
build community and occasionally
overlooked areas of residence life he
served as chair of dunk mentoring Harlem
middle school students in was a
corporate development intern for Hilton
Worldwide business insights and
analytics intern with the NBA his
positivity attention to detail and
passion for involvement at Columbia are
greatly appreciated by both staff
members and peers congratulations Jeremy
[Applause]
the alumni association achievement award
is given to Raj Anoosh Sharma who I knew
who is judged to be most outstanding in
qualities of minds character and service
to the College
Anu served as the Columbia College
student council vice president for
finance and brought an intelligent and
pathetic and measured approach to
decision-making in this role a news was
lauded for a commitment to transparency
integrity and inclusivity and spent
hours of each day discussing and
dissecting challenging and difficult
decisions
Anuj has a natural candor and affable
spirit that a departed upon us all
congratulations the news
[Applause]
it is my it is now my pleasure to
introduce the co-chairs of a class of
the 2017 senior fund committee Ravi Jane
Cena and Lainey McGehee for the
presentation of the class gift thank you
Doug
over the past few weeks we have lived
out both the joys and the sorrows of
experiencing our Columbia laughs these
moments have shaped our experiences as
students of Columbia College though our
individual adventures have all been
unique we can nonetheless unite over our
shared journey of being students at this
incredible university the senior fund is
one way of making these moments possible
for future students a way for our class
to give back to incoming lions and to
ensure that they get to experience all
of the things that made our time here so
transformative and memorable especially
given that only 60% of our experience
here is funded by tuitions together
over 400 members of our class have made
a gift this year additionally some
seniors have opted into Dean Valentini
3-2-1 challenge committing to give for
three years I send to alumni events and
challenge one friend to do the same this
level of participation qualifies us for
an exceptionally generous $100,000
matching gifts from Charles Santoro
class of 1982
[Music]
none of our work this year would have
been possible without the tireless
energy and effort the senior fund
executive committee please stand so we
can thank you for your dedication this
year it's been fantastic working with
you
[Applause]
Thank You Dean Valentini please join us
it is an honor to present you the senior
class gift this scroll and book contain
the names and signatures of the senior
donors who have made our success
possible and for the class of 2017 we
feel incredibly lucky to be part of a
class that cares so much about the
future of this university thank you for
your enthusiasm for your passion and for
your love of each other and for our
school remember remember that you're
part of the Columbia family for life so
stay connected and continue to be active
members of this incredible community
thank you and congratulations to the
class of 2017
[Applause]
good morning president Bollinger
president wolf president right force I'm
surrounded by presence this morning
trustees of the University vice
president Madigan faculty colleagues
alumni in the parade of classes and
especially members of the class of 1967
who will soon celebrate their 50th
reunion family and friends welcome again
to Columbia College class day and to you
the 1172 members of the class of 2017
congratulations today is your last day
at the senior dinner two weeks ago I
told you the class of 2013 that you were
a ten as in the highest rank on a scale
of one to ten and said that you were one
of only four classes in the 263 year
history of Columbia College that could
be a ten I gave this as a puzzle for you
to solve because I always have a puzzle
at senior dinner and the answer which
many of you figured out right away given
that you are Columbia College students
was that only for Columbia college class
years have digits that add up to 10 1801
1900 2008 and 2017 but in saying that
the class yeah but in saying that the
class of 2017 was a 10 I was offering
more than a puzzle I was leading up to
today's class Day speech to say
something more and something more
significant to be ranked 10 on a scale
of one to ten means to be complete to
lack nothing the academic regalia you
are each wearing signifies that as a
graduate you have become complete and
lacked nothing according to the
requirements of Columbia College you
have completed the core curriculum a
major or a concentration or more than
one at least 124 credits and as Sheena
write indicated one swim test that
accomplishment is what you sought when
you enrolled at the college and each of
you will be congratulated individually
for that individual achievement your
name will be called today you will have
a handshake with me and then with
president Bollinger and cheers from
family and friends but at senior dinner
I ranked you as a class
as attend to focus your attention on you
as a group who together are complete
lacking for nothing when all 1172 of you
are considered together join together
add it up just as the digits in 2017 add
up to 10 there is enormous pressure for
each of us individually to aspire to be
complete to lack for nothing
right now and always there's a
serendipity today this is in Jordana's
remarks as well thank you Jordanna whose
vocabulary I can't use in front of a
microphone but I can't endorse Jordanna
is evidence that Jersey Girls should be
a compliment not a diss each of us will
make mistakes be confused misjudged
situations fall short perform in
adequately completeness lacking for
nothing individually will elude most of
us should we stop trying no rather we
should adjust our sights from the
individual outcome to the individual
effort as I have expressed to you many
times with the maxim there is no way to
happiness happiness is the way and we
should also adjust our sights more
importantly from an exclusive emphasis
on ourselves individually to what we can
do together because what each of us can
achieve together can exceed even what
the most nearly complete of us can
achieve alone to say that you the class
of 2017 is a 10 by adding you up the way
the digits 2 0 1 7 add up to 10
is actually a flawed metaphor it implies
that the whole of you is simply the sum
of you individually but that isn't true
because of a concept called synergy
the term synergy meaning working
together conveys that the creation of a
whole is actually can be greater than
the simple sum of its parts
synergy is created when individual parts
interact such that their value goes
beyond that contributed by each
individual part that is true of
inanimate entities a great sports car is
great because of the interaction of its
components not their individual
excellence our Columbia campus is
majestic because of the relationship
among its buildings a relationship that
gives a value that transcends their
individual architectural merit it is
even more important in human endeavors
our Columbia a cappella group notes and
keys is more than the voices of its
individual singers and the true value of
the Columbia College core curriculum is
the relationship of the works you read a
value that far exceeds the value of
reading any of them individually this
kind of synergy was our goal when we
brought you all to campus four years ago
we admitted you to Columbia College
because we believed that you were the
applicants best able to profit from and
contribute to the experience of Columbia
College best able to create a synergy
that would enhance your individual
success and satisfaction it is what has
brought you to this place today it is
the synergy that enabled your beginner's
mind you have contributed yes indeed you
have contributed to the undergraduate
experience of each other its artists
writers scientists athletes and
entrepreneurs to create a collective
value that goes well beyond the sum of
your individual contributions Sheena
Wright has told us how she contributed
to and profited from here experience
here at Columbia College in an interview
with Columbia College today the college
alumni magazine that all of you will
soon became begin receiving she said of
her undergraduate years
quote it was a great way to learn about
organization and leadership how do you
organize a
effective around an issue and achieve
results unquote she not only majored in
history and sociology but as she has
already told you she was active in many
groups and activities on campus and
these communities these experiences
helped her land where she is today in
fact when she received the John J Award
for distinguished professional
achievement from Columbia College last
year Sheena spoke of the and I quote
scaffold of love and support and
nurturance that came from every strata
of this place including her classmates
her professors her coach the financial
aid and dining hall staff even the deans
she said others saw in her what she
didn't and instilled in her the
confidence that helped her grow today
she knows work continues to depend on a
very particular synergy the United Way
the organization that she leads uses
what is called a collective impact
approach to bring families out of
poverty
this approach brings together different
entities corporate community and
government partners to achieve a result
a hole that the entities could not
achieve alone a hole that is greater
than the sum of its parts
I urge you to seek out endeavors that
offer that synergy that give you the
opportunity to achieve more working with
others than you yourself could even if
you think you individually can get a
rating of ten from your boss in that
performance evaluation even if you think
that big research proposal you are
writing by yourself will score a ten
from the reviewers even if you think the
judges will award you a ten for your
solo musical performance because the act
of working together with others might
lead to something better for everyone
working together even you you might be
an 11 or a 12 not just a 10 because that
synergy scale goes well above 10 that
synergy is what multiplies the value of
Columbia College 4500 students 1,000
faculty 300 staff members
and nearly 50,000 alumni of Columbia
College whose interactions make
something of greater value than the sum
of our individual contributions it is
the reason I can say Columbia College is
the greatest College in the greatest
university in the greatest city in the
world through the Columbia College
Alumni Association we help you will
continue to profit from and contribute
to that synergy to contribute to the
lives of other Colombians to your own
classmates to other alumni who have
preceded you to the students who will
come after you and all along the way
take with you
Pantone 292 the the blue that surrounds
you today the blue that I introduced you
to at convocation on August 26 2013 on
this very spot as a visual reminder of
your connections to one another and even
more importantly take with you every day
and use beginner's mind it is the secret
to your success as Sheena said you will
find yourselves in rooms when you will
be the least experienced people that's a
real advantage because as you know in
the beginner's mind there are many
possibilities in the experts mind there
are few despite your expertness
today continue to be a beginner that
will be the secret to your success so I
will close by saying thank you for
coming to Columbia College thank you for
all that you have taught me and yes you
have thank you for all that you have
taught us thank you for what you have
taught one another thank you for what
you have given the thank you for what
you have given to Columbia
congratulations to all of you to your
families to your professors to your
coaches to your advisers to your mentors
class of 2017 you are not only a ten you
are the best class ever
I now have the pleasure of introducing
Lisa Bollinger president of Columbia
University Lee became Columbia
University's 19th president in 2002 and
is the longest-serving Ivy League
president under his leadership Columbia
stands at the very top rank of great
research universities distinguished by
comprehensive academic excellence and
innovated and sustainable approach to
global engagement and this institutions
most ambitious campus expansion in over
a century and he is leading our great
University into a new capital campaign
Columbia commitments which is dedicated
to creating ever more synergies between
students and faculty to make our
contribution to our world ever greater
president Bollinger is Columbia's first
set low professor of the University a
member of the Law School faculty and one
of the country's foremost First
Amendment scholars his most recent book
is uninhibited robust and wide open a
free press for a new century president
Bollinger is the person who tomorrow at
commencement will confer on you quote
the degree for which you have qualified
unquote I will recommend you for that
degree but only he can confer it and you
will not actually graduate and until he
does so please you have a most hearty
and appreciative welcome to president
Bollinger
I want to extend my warmest
congratulations as well to you the class
of 2017 and to the parents and families
and friends and since I will be speaking
to tomorrow as Jim just said I don't
want you to become tired of me and I
will be very brief
this morning there are really just two
things that I want to say the first is
about the importance of the kind of
education you have received and its
relation to the state of the world we
are living in today
personally I have to say I have never
admired the liberal arts curriculum and
especially ours with its rich and
authentic core curriculum nor believed
it to be more meaningful and practical
for a society than I do
at this moment if I could do
if I could do anything right now
I would mandate that every political
leader in the world return to school
preferably preferably to Columbia and to
learn the basic intellectual skills and
the substance of a liberal arts
education over time many people have
tried to articulate the rationales for
the study of the liberal arts in today's
world I see anew its role to know or to
have studied seriously the reflections
on life Beauty ethics power and politics
and many other subjects of the finest
minds over many centuries that at the
very least makes one conscious of the
constraints on our naturally
undisciplined minds that are needed for
a civilized society constraints like
reasons the requirement of giving
coherent explanations for what we
believe in do and living and living
within the boundaries of fundamental
principles such as justice and the rule
of law the liberal arts education the
liberal arts education through immersion
practice and repetition makes us capable
of being embarrassed if we fall short of
living by these constraints we seem to
be losing that capacity for self
embarrassment
there are moments there are special
moments in history typically right after
people have suffered some Grievous
breakdown of civilization when remedies
are sought and new programs are
introduced to make what has just
happened less likely to happen in the
future such was that remarkable period
right after the devastation of World War
one when the core curriculum was
conceived as were the Pulitzer Prizes
and as was the as were the very first
Supreme Court cases defining what
freedom of speech impressed me we're
following the Second World War when the
School of International and public
affairs was created and General Studies
and more broadly the United Nations and
the Universal Declaration on human
rights and the array of international
organizations we live with today it is
worth asking whether we are about to
enter another such fertile period our
efforts at Columbia to become more
engaged with the world's issues from our
neighborhood to the nation and unto the
world by bringing the capacities of the
Academy along with outside partners to
help solve human problems certainly
arise out of a belief that the world's
problems have moved way ahead of our
capacities to address them and
universities need to step forward to
help but my main point is that you have
received what you have received here at
Columbia and in Columbia College is the
very very best of what a liberal arts
education can offer and do I hope that
you do not now or ever take it for
granted and I hope you insist on its
relevance to whatever part of the world
you choose to spend your life
congratulations and I look forward to
seeing you tomorrow
[Applause]
Thank You president Bollinger now we
invite each graduate to the stage for
recognition advisors from the James H
and Christine Turk barrack Center for
student advising who have supported
these students throughout their Columbia
careers have the honor of reading the
names of each graduate as they process
across the stage to be congratulated by
Dean Valentini and president Bollinger I
ask that you please refrain from
applause until all members of the class
have returned to their seats Jordana
Sophie Naren Michael J Abulafia Quang
Huy Huy Alexander Akira kin
Mark Stevenson brathwaite Caleb Alan
Oldham wina long Kristen de Geopark
Nicholas Wolf ermine Madison rush Joan
Brennan Keane mendes shawn Francis Ryan
Jake drab nerve Julia Julia Megan Davis
parada hey soos Christopher Reyes
Rodriguez
Derek Lee Louisa carpenter winch jessica
dawn Swanson Kunal Sanjeev Kanodia tane
bond occur a Mars ad Christopher Chen
Briana Renee Leslie sky Elsa Mateus Ian
Hoover a news Sharma jeremy cooper Colin
Howard aundrea why Ron Yano Kareem
knotter
Lanie McGee
Ravi Jane Sinha died Alan Rajaratnam
George leo
Jennifer Paula Petrovich Vincent song
Franco Madalena Madonna
hadass markovin Nicholas Nicoletta
Alexa pulo Jorge Santiago Pena Torres
Kenna Marie Arana Stephanie Eileen
Moreno Hannah Hart
Susan Laura Jiao William Michael
cornacchia Richard politi Lauren rivers
Wardlaw Sophie Francis McAlister
Chiron wake Juan Griffith house Sean UN
Katie - here Kuryakin more caucus sorry
David Mottola Pedro's fremitus Taylor
Vanessa Smith Brianna Lee brown youngly
Kevin Choi Rodrigo Manu Ben
Lily shuffler
Xena Lunia Stockwell Evan car
Benjamin lisanna Druckman Andre Stillman
Adam Kunal gteen Shah a locum gone dark
Brian F Abu chakra Tracy King Sal Sarah
Aneesa right
Rohan Shang Christy Alex Jenkins
jennifer marie Olsen Emma Bettles Vogler
a Lu Wan Chai Tara Stephen Camille
smooth Peterson Mia Peres Vivian Chen
case and Rao Kevin Patrick sites William
Brandon Rodriguez how in Ames a cool
rock Benjamin Aaron Libman chase Michael
Morris eg Jung
Phoebe Alexis judge hey soos Abraham
more avaya Rebecca hope Gelman Bradley
Gerard Davison Joey MIT roof honest
Zachary Charles flick Alexandra
Villarreal Gabriella and Levy Kevin
Christopher Pollack Samuels qianxi shall
Damon ex parte a la me day underneath
there a du pays your Noah Karanga
Elizabeth Dakota Monroe Adan machiya
Maura Raymond Eugene Jenny Jang shreya
vista Praga da
Judy though a little bit challenged ooh
Dorothy fangs Rebecca FEI peng chau mean
wong-tam uno Tania Brown soo Park Demi
Henricus Sarah Briggs read Imani Jalen
James Gabriela Azusa
Alina Bosley Matthew Edward Tremblay
alia Padilla ayakashi no Zaki Asha
Banerjee Emily Claggett Emily Atterbury
burns
Isabella Michels German Rosner Shawn
Brennan hi Quon Lee Karen you on Claudia
Patricia Della Valle Miranda Sarah
Rebecca contour Tiffany Holly warmer
Cristina P tuga Tristan Cara moon Kelly
ran Lou Catherine Jew Kim Christopher
young Jean jingly Jamison Randall
McBride
Kevin Palma Raimundo pantoja area
Ashley Shen Jesse Alexander Silbert
Selena Missy Olek Unni ambassy odo
an adjuster on Brewer qianxi Amelia
Lewis Edwards Elena melodia Klein Yijing
Jean Mira French Oh Carolyn Blevins
Korean ah he burrows Nico Rodriguez
voice our evening Deville Diane
Ramona bleed air Jennifer Ginsu cube
Emily male ow Amelia Laurette wallet
Divya Agarwal
Bryan Douglas Manzo Raymond Quon Lee
Emily Chen Lorna Mateo Sofia Pune shade
Rhea Taylor Genesis Garfield
Rachel Kapoor Nova Cheng Li and Hong Soo
Jin Yong Yong chew Lauren Elizabeth Maya
Ramachandran Courtney Lee Janice
Christopher Z when bharata's Lima
McKenna Gilliland Aaron Elise flowers
lnb page Cheyenne Courtney Stewart
Elizabeth Roxy Madison Schmidt McCarthy
Mariano Nunez Ian covert kanika Verma
Jane you Rebecca - Wren Irit walk for
vilya Willy bro dong
hardik Devon Shaw Whitney Shannon alam
Tiffany fam
pratishta Jarek Allah Alejandra Maria
Cassano Linda Naomi Blanton Katie Wang
Diana penguin
Jacqueline atrial rope Chapin Robin
Christopher young joy Chang Jaime Jing
ji Chang Phillip Geoffrey Michael Robert
makovski David Levi meadow Western
Jackson Homer Solomon mate
Christophe and Paulette
Jason Gally Thomas Kingman rotten Justin
M Brielle Hyun Kim Sun woo han hee Joo
hee Eun Chan Ho Yin Christine Kim Thomas
and Chao nan Nataraj Louis Efrain
Rodriguez David died : locating Ahana
Macon Albert Park even Masahiro woo
coil man lien Steven - Claire su Kwong
Kavya Shivashankar site yeah free toffee
Megan Maria Felder Cheryl and crispo
Grace and Potter
Kendall Charles pace Nathan Lee give
Elvis we've came Helen mingwan chance
Amy see up Annie son han-soo Samantha
King Adrienne Oscar Montoto Jason Lee
Reed
Kevin you Jonathan son
Helen yang o'kiku Maura
Candice Michelle Simone fuller kevin
chen emma claire O'Hanlon christie
prettier corn Rebecca
Claire Fisher Maya baby Amin visible
Claire McGrory Eliza Zachary Charles
Penniman Michael James Alvarez Tolu a
beacon Wayne Mitchell bang you King whoo
Christine Samantha Wang Emily - Dylan
Shannon were a hollow Elena loose
Gaither Shing Shing Zhang Jabril cook
George Andrew styler van Anson
Maya Vikram Pandit Sofia
Elizabeth forum juliana del pilar
quartzes Catherine Patrice hetzer el
Shana was with Nikki
Allison Alana Malin Lea Marie hey Wendy
Fang Lilia Jimenez and Draya Pacheco
Francis Paola Reyes or zopo Carrie Lee
Justin William a Minetti Kathryn
Lorraine colorin Benjamin boob Nadine
selasa law Nadine Sakhalin Sinisa Singh
kayla marie Bozeman Hannah Rose nyl
Khosla Alexander loin ik Terrace and
wall
Katie Wisner makhmud Ricardo de Luca
Akuma Kendall jaren Jackson loose Joseph
Petra sacks Christopher Matthew mccomber
Jeffrey Reginald Coby a med rad halal
chicken
Alisa palm Cathy blow Isaac's leader
Jonathan Katya layer Hoffman Nicholas
Bharathi partha Sharma
Kyle Patel got michael tritter daniela
Croswell sama acai Samuel Abraham :
Lucas Philips color Matteo libelous
William Otto Wilson people brought James
Kenyon Benjamin Powell Kaplan Charles
Malcolm
Anthony panada Thiago presto called neva
no David Jimenez Restrepo Richard BAM
Brian Aubrey Smith Christopher Graham
Danielle gray Jacob Sean husana Bobby
Troy Ronald Hembree Christopher Michael
array Oz Matthew John less injure Nikita
a leg bata Rinku johnson mine Vincent
Saloni
Michael Milton fecha Austin Victor
conifer Edward Choi Yeo Joo Hwan
Nikhil Raghav ara Bharadwaj Gregory's
long bad rule Fred Lee John Coburn
Darius I'm sorry Diego Annelle Cheng Chi
hoon Jacqueline Chula Adil Google
Christopher Derek George Nicholas Nemo
Raphael shibez nor will Christopher
Caleb Allison Jeffery Danielle Oh Reba
both Alito Antonia casseras
Nicolas Edward Nia Andrea Hollister
Bernier Terra serene matada Rekha
Priscilla Kennedy Nikita
Mary singer Eddie Jordana Gabrielle
remedy Alexandra Mary O'Keefe Gabrielle
April Leah Myers Madeline Claire
Matthews Ileana cane field
Simon Schwartz Salvatore a veto
bourguignon a forest Lindbergh Davis
Faison Kotori a Lamont a toddler Michael
Sonny minute Allah
Agassi Lorenzo Jordan Bradford where did
he go
Maya Capel Nicola Samantha rose Trabuco
Alexandra Midway Luna Eve ray Angela
Mestre Olivia and mutter a leaf Callie
an iguana
Jobrani Pethick Sarah Park Lauren de la
Fuente Sofia tres la ra Freeland Alice
Robert Collins
Kunal Anita Camus Julian Ernst right
Emily and Liang Emma Catherine II Canary
Jenny late' OVA Katina mouth shocker
Renata Rogers castle
Benjamin got Zener been Sklar Kremen sir
Gregory Conrad Spaulding Joshua Benjamin
sued man through moral Johnston Audrey
Elena Watkins Britain Louisa fawning
Michael Vlad Costin Corbett Johnson
Walser Mary Catherine Fitzpatrick's
Emanuel ray Walton Trevor Alexander dr.
Noah
Liam Rifkin Channing friends John
Francis mellow Emma
Olivia Volk swetha kadali Jared Michael
Katz
Gregory Alan Watson Cameron miles done
Denzel Deacon Bray
- ray Douglas Joseph Tanner Terry Isan
Freya gossamer elke Miriam Belle gutsy
Anna grace new Oh sue Thomas Edward
Norman Maria Anna Mauro Montes edita
mayor ELISA Rose Feinberg Alleluia
Stephanie Cabrera Caballero Cristina
Pelin Laura hunter
Jasmine Alisa Feliciano philippe de avea
bell booth Paris Claire Wang Chan Kelly
Cheng Fernanda Vanessa Pacheco Julia
London Mallika Patkar Alexandra white
Haru stray Eva Krusty mere gum Nishka
Paulo Mousavi Claire H sir
Madeleine Delaney hunter Lydia Peterson
naga hoots Karen Tong Isabel Rosberg
Sophia Hill Julia she man Jong Amy Wong
James Heppenstall
Keon Madigan Emily man Eric comments
Dhupia Nelson Michael Paul stars
Jacob miles Seidman Bianca Marie
Guerrero Ava Kenya xma shreya detalle
Jose Francisco Miguel Alexis treasurer
Juan Carlos Castro helm
Annabel Blanco maria antnia do rail
Samantha FA bottom Tanzer Peter
Tewksbury Kobe Jurado Richard Thomas
Wolfe
Jonathan Eric Josephson lesser Brian
Edwards cylinder
Rahul Kapoor Gabriel Nicolas Uribe
Matthew Mark Taylor Alexandra Kathleen
sure Monique Jones Sophia Williams virus
Chanel Tamsin Maria
go jasmine Cleo a FEMA a coup fo Ashley
Imani Cartwright
Lucy Marita Jacob Kylie Werner Natalia
Romano speaker Jacqueline
Olga Basulto mark Philip Villanueva Jame
Carol show
Alexandre power Anna
Miren Carano Julianne Moore as Lou
Diana Liang Sachi alum Prabhu bottle
Rachel Gaeta tortora titles Kevin James
staples Benjamin Philip Davidoff Adriana
Perez rotondo Theodora Elaine Davis Alex
broth lofty Gillian
no Madeline Clark Steinberg
Carolyn King Adam Lieber Karl yen Makeda
johannes Anna Elizabeth
Brockton Isabel Maria Maria Megan and
Kincaid Solomon Gabriel speckler Blake
Carlton album Jessica Ariel cat go Emily
grace Sato and Carolyn Negev Ani
Maria Monserrat Martinez bee hoon Shawn
Choi George Q Graham Stanley go Betty
Bennet Wilcox Juliet Brooke
Jacob Nnamdi Umbara
Jonathan Brandon young Christine Adrian
Nelson Joseph Michael Roth Alan
Jacqueline Marie Kovarik Molina Galano
Justin Chang the tacho Borak spotter
p-kun you Yin Catherine moon Alec Lee
Jonathan wrong Lee Frank Wang Zhong Jack
Jia Rong Chen Joshua Andrew Lewin Jacob
Ian Adam Hewitt Antonio Huerta Patricia
pal Toby so hon John Aneesa career Oh
Janine Rio Alma Samantha
Perez Yves McMillion thing Audrey she
dancing Lou Angela Wang three car garage
Justin Evan come a eight and Julian
Richardson Tristan Edgar van Bhima John
Walter Stokes - Stephanie Tanya Caitlin
Louise Hills Carlos Martin via Eric
James Bastille William on ek Carson Noah
Isaac grammage Michelle Lucille crow
feather Jacob Daniel Delbert Daniel
Halpern Sugarman
may a yoga show John Lim Luca qing-ge
Lee after hearin roll
min-jung Oh gun-woo Lee Elizabeth self
Zoe Levine jeiza mone Robinson Elora
Ella
Safran Manuela Valyria dos Santos maven
Toby
Meredith do Bree Laville yas'm fora
hyacinth a and Dallas Walker
Kendall renee smith christian Lundberg
Edward soon Tang Bo Yong Cheng hey soos
Fred Wilson great stamp Jeremy
David Corrin franceska Ravel molesky
Jacqueline angel Santos Jeffrey gorta
maker
Daniel Evan singer Madeline Louise
Martin Raghav Bonzo
Ethan Robert grant re n ROM Alfred East
Side Kayla Maloney Tania Ricky whoo
Joshua Gabriel cold Fatima and makalya
Morales Jessica Katherine Glick slogan
Samuel Fitzgerald Purcell Teicher Ssang
Yong Li Anusha pondering Sara shorty
Aisha and Agarwal
Raphael Schwab the nuts Kapoor Samantha
Mia Matteo Jake Michael okay Michael Lee
Pinkham Sameer Robert canning Jeremy
Feinberg Joshua Yanke Oh Mason Murrieta
Gregory Barton mom Jim Martin Alexander
Ridge Caitlin rose
Colin Palmer Rana or macaques oi Sara
Wong pit Caitlin Nicole Fung Brianna
Ashley Cunningham Angela batter a cozia
a med admin Erica reaching Chen Vivian
Cheng Jordan Neve William Jose Antonio
Prieta devildis E or e 8 the third
Jennifer and Luca Giovanna krauser
Fitzgerald erica lynn Glazer emerald
Patricia flora Smith Kaitlyn Loftus
Lilly goddess Mandi bodis Daniel Joseph
Merlot Laura
Emily Pena Susanna Rachel Cohen Sonja
Peter Eck Margot Chris Berg Celia de
neige Frick Jennifer Bella Shahar
Catherine and Ruster hold Kendall Nicole
Samuel Elias Lake Oh Maximilian Caine
Martin belong Leo laocoon by arrow ye
wounds
Tristan grant Stidham Clement jelly
David bgo William Grayson Snider
lauren marie Diaz Armando Jose Jose Juan
Leone coral Dillon Okabe Joe death
Leora Balin Sasha and Nicole science
Saloni Jane Carolyn am bender Kaler Kate
Mills Rebecca
Lillian bards Meredith Calbre Daniel
Schwartz Sarah Jane rickland Rachel
Blumenthal Cheryl Merlin
Eliana bet slur Michaela Bernstein Jason
lemon Eisner Matthew Margolin Parker
Joshua Jesse Schwartz David Joseph
Peyser
Melissa Kaufman Gomez Nadia Lynn Nick
karela Paul Alexander bloom Sarah Diane
Deshawn beau Moscow Sheila Diane
Alexander Molly Engle Raina Murray
Robert Kesem Ellen Samuel Adam Bogle at
Balzac
Lillian lien-tsai Renfro Zachary Ross
wife Amanda kappa white Ariana ray Irene
who Zeng Alexander Richard Febreze Eric
ho Andrew Laden Julia Kim left Kaveri
Sengupta young Abraham Murray John
Gillis Davenport Daniel mark ray dog
Brian Madani Cameron Howard Dempsey Jack
Alan Foster
Connor Jay Fraser Molly Zeb curve Emily
Adele Clifford
Emily bajjali ball Ming Jian hongou
Kenneth Lee John yang Sheree Jang Yi
NEMA shoe
Shin Wang Ming xiaochun hi J Kennedy Joo
Mario Kelly T Makayla Jane O'Connor
Alexander Scott Reynolds Marshall Thomas
Bozeman no immense Tourette's
Theodore Finkelstein William Francis
panic
Jane Zachary Warren Wei Lee Jung Chung
care et Enric Wong Zechariah rain
caloric Sarah and Barone Audrey bar
Vinita Andrew J Zola Margaret lychee Lu
su golf Eagle Sutter
Jeremy Douglas Sherman Nancy Taylor
Quinn amici Schumer with Brennan
Michaela Branca Andrew Vincenzo Lewis
canary Luis Alberto Morgan oddo
recess Minh Williams Samuel heaven rich
Isaac Alvin April yong-su choke Sabbath
Demetrius P 3ds Amy no Elwood Matthew
Jean ocean box
[Applause]
Nicholas Hewson Halleck Alex elodea
pedal Janet Chen Shannon sjow Aaron
Robert wrote I can don't home David
Lewis Maalouf June when Deng and Monique
safe Jordan Mosley Brandon you chen-wong
carla marie Rodriguez Ortiz
Rosalyn Raylan REM saw Andrew Ryan bear
tougher cloutie Alastair Lightfoot
Clement Connor Daniel Coughlin Colin
Joel King Jeffrey P Lazar
Daniel David Cabot Jose Andres Solorio
Elizabeth Lou Riley Jones Shanique
vassal Rochelle Jamila Wilbon kin-san
faith or aqua Brianna
Antonia made charisma deonda price
Manama Elsayed Laura joy Alton Morgan
Alicia cues
hey Jana and gutter Kiana Theodora Lee
no destiny John Franklin dhaniya halacha
you Aisha see me so lucky for eg Zachary
half Seligmann Karen
Benjamin Jacob Riis Gianluigi De Falco
Kate Elizabeth Stanley
Jaclyn gage King Catherine Ilona web
Lena green blacker Brittany page Gibson
Alexandra melanoma better
Nicholas a bachina Alvaro Biaggio Rossi
Edmund Harrison Bros Michael crow Chico
Kenny Michael James Kiehl D John Wilding
Sebastian chain Maurice Friedlander
Goldberg Andrew Charles pesky Samantha
our Williger Canada often choke graham
David Gordon Johnson
Cynthia Vanessa Fabian Nicholas Emery
Kirsch Andrew Misaki Shem Carolyn Miller
joy Elizabeth Judd Madison Bentley
Pollock John huntin matthew ellis Panton
sally Morgan Lindsey
Anna Sophia Calatrava le Katherine
Dominguez applaud Garson T Syed a signal
washa Julian Victor Robles
Nathan Crawford barrage Benjamin Moses
Schneider Daniel Eduardo Roanoke ample
Max Potter's Bernstein Angela Gabriella
deucey Phillip Burnett Henry thorn of
Bram Giulio Joseph Salerno Jason hammer
Bacaro Daniel hammer Vacarro a negro
Emily shear Benjamin Whitmore Hanser
Jordan Berkeley Brewington Camila
Oliveira pop Ezra cougar Ayesha or
guarna Petrovka Boris Jonathan Steven
Fuhrer
Robert Aldana Rachel kaya Ning Arielle
Coughlin Lucas Babbitt in Maxine's the
guy law Cooper Reba Glyn John's
Treadwell merwin Rebecca Lauren mana he
Sonia Gil Aparicio Zhu Li moon Haley
Lucille's of vixx Qian Gillian Parlin
Kaylie Nicole asking
my a Mackenzie's on Dell Allison's
lawyer a band of quark Jada young
Michael Davenport when Xining Evan
Taylor Clinton Christian padilha Mia
Beatriz Santiago Virginia foo Gary
Bahuguna Siobhan's the Malta car
Chelsea che cose on Allah Creek
Felicia Wednesday Lopez Colorado
Alexander obradovich Kayla Elizabeth
bevel Collette Sultana Joseph Mulholland
a vino arm Joseph Silman Nathan Herschel
Levine's being kosher bond Valley amber
autumn Sun Richard Chang Shannon
Catherine ship leaves a lease alyssa
marie rhodium shall be Aaron Unger
Joshua Kim got Jia Hong Chen Gary shoe
Williams K won't Yong Quan Allison shoe
Jill chow Tanya Lu panel Lou Christopher
Chu kirusha and filet arjuna walkway on
day J Christian Fitzgerald William when
you Tang Williams whoa Nathan Kim
William styler morn Hin wig Cameron
knives elect Jackson Augustine Conway
Christian piers Conway gianmarco Raya
Marc Anthony's sees left Tyler Jane
kissed Oh Kathy Anna is about food
Kristy choice Laura Tang I mean she
Ching Wong Winston Yin windlass this was
an Andrew Ling David Haitian Breton
Allen serving Erin shoe Shawnee Hamza
the likies Gigi Menominee Charlotte
Lepic Nicholas pellon all Zachary Joshua
burned and Ponce Imbler alia of mohair
Baba aunt Sophie Louise Schmidt
Francesca Danielle Polly Carm
Tiffany May Mariko Kenai chapatti Verma
Laura - Tanika
Daniel Ron Prinn Ferguson Catherine homo
Samuel Norman Klein Markman Emilia Maria
Alvarez Torres Sarah
Elena Martinez Sousa Isabella and Andrew
Bazo alana marie zelaya flores
joseph Louie John Morris Diego rosettes
Camila Mercedes van evict Amira Singh
pile Leonard Marshall Lindsey Nicole
Gonzalez Carolyn League kettle Sophia
Victoria Campuzano
Lindsay Jane Robertson egon von Conway
choppy Jiang Yu Shu Han Robert Bickford
Matthew Jonah tab Joseph Edward Sandhya
Aaron Marvin Kenan Gira's Selina Homer
maria laura Balthazar Martin Mora
Montana
Carlos Salman Ruiz Julian Armando Nevada
bail emelina Glinka s-- Mary Elizabeth
constants William V Classen Samuel
Walter click ething zhang yogi Hong Jang
Ginga o Wong Juliana Teresa remark Rin
Victoria Harris
Abigail Mary Porter Julia Gabrielle
garage Zoe Menon Miranda Kate litwalk
Olivia Rose Barry
Kaylie Marie Peterson yeoju cherry poo
Katherine Schneiderman Miguel lpez de
Alda Marielle gobo Becker Jackie Marie
Lawson Leopoldo Angelou Jeremy sibel
Luis Sanchez
Gabriella ELISA Reynoso
Amar'e our tankard Vanessa
Erica onions Oh Kaitlin H pet Rebecca
Gruber Taylor Murray fog Marilyn grace
Minton Alexandra marina Diaz Aleman Noel
Nelson Wyman chinkyu Lindsay hope remark
Benjamin McBride deal Keenan James Piper
Jonah Hennig Robert Anthony Napolitano
John Hastings Boyle Julia Sana's Lord OE
Nicole Marie de Tomaso Jude see a diva
Kanta
Alexander Malik Curtis you young Joe
grace Elizabeth Taylor Noah
Lucien Lartigue Dominic James Petula
Haley Brooke Mendelssohn Camille who
Devon towel Natalie Tanner Sydney Quinn
Segal Daisy and Chasse
Sarah Albright Grbac Kenza been brahim
Ariane stone
so we ELISA Jacob Cameron Robert
McGinnis Flavia Logano Catalina peccato
Aidan Slavin Jeremy Bennett stop the
Reina Sofia Garcia Bonucci Reina Barker
Anna Barbara Williams Vega cam Ronnie
Hannah ruse Tommy Samantha Tyler Georgia
and Tuttle Sarah Marie Burke max
Pasternak Norris Kate signal pair Tracy
Shen Nia Brown arena tab leva William
just Laird
Eliza Barry Callahan
Olivia Cecile Harrison David Alexander
Hoffman Brittany Danielle Wade Ronald
Derrick Busby jr.
Alexander Fremantle John Paul Baisley
Breanna Kathleen Lenihan Erica Megan
Johnson Christina
Elizabeth May Farrell Alex
Omar Longoria I said to Rihanna berry
rose and II true love max
Ian face Miranda leave Ava mint Evan
Siegel mark Pietro Zhang como Serena
Reina Pereira Carolyn chihwan ho pity
you Bo Han Dylan Olivia who's occur
Adam Josh was Shapiro Zachary Kent
Matthew forest Evan garnet Michael
Alexander Zach's that's the big deal in
Tiffany of bouquet organ pipe Tanya a
molta a gunfight andrs garca an ELISA
Meza Johnson Miranda of Raquel Ian Mari
Amanda Funabashi marina rebecca chan
Iram Alex Avensis Carol hello Madeline
Polanco Veronica and donghae's Serena
Doreen's Bronfman Alice Lilly's song
Darlene Garcia Annette a merit Finnegan
Marley Naomi
Marius Lauren ryuko for Kumamoto Alison
H Chang
Tanvi boxer Danielle Jean climbs Peter
Winston hopper Andrew Ascencio
Meredith Parsons Hilton Devin Claire
Roper Victoria Leanne Oliver Larissa and
McPhee
Carolyn Alice Gallagher Aria Rose talcum
Maggie
lemon Deville ger Sarah joy Ruthie
Kyle Matthew bottle Minh Danny
Kim Oh song Quan Alan
Shin Elliott Shu Guang Wu choice
Joshua Kevin Baker Richard Greer Soper
Brian sorrowful Ryan Marissa Batra
Garret Christopher Roberts Nicholas
Francisco Erikson Shane Michael Adams
Ryan McCoy marks Bruce Lee growls Carina
Melendez step Simon Davis Katie Julia
Jung Jennifer Chen mark Kenan Gore three
Alex knew when Rebecca a Rob Charlene
Francois and Laurie white paint on
Lakeisha Logan William Erikson Harry
Steven Scott Eric Alexander Guardiola
Gregory Charles ducat do shark Ethan
Daniel Hudson karate
Alec Jastrow Jasmine Natalie Merce Peter
Thomas Leon Arbuckle's the second
and Tyler came through on a meal hotel
Daniel edge expense Sophie repeal will
outdo Elena
Shanthi laksana Daniel Barr katana bra
Haruka
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen please join me in
congratulating the Columbia College
class of 2017
we will close these class two exercises
with a singing of fantasy and war lion
war led by the cliffhangers we invite
you to sing along the lyrics may be
found in your programs cliffhangers
[Music]
when the ball in the hole be the bay
maintained here at all Columbia nowadays
we can praise sporting teams again use
the hydro despised love Amana
Morningside Honolulu and like to be
[Music]
Thank You cliffhangers our celebrations
continue beyond this event University
commencement takes place tomorrow and
that evening the Empire State Building
will be illuminated in Columbia blue - 9
- as a special tribute to you our new
graduates as we bring this celebration
to a close I ask that you remain in your
seats until the stage recessional has
concluded but first ladies and gentlemen
I am pleased to present to you our
newest alumni the Columbia College class
of 2017
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]